ก็สวัสดีครับสวัสดีค่ะครูนี้กันเจสวัสดี
นักเรียนทุกคนด้วยสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
วันนี้สบายดีไหมสบายดีค่ะครูนิแล้วคุณนี้
นะคะสบายดีไหมคะวันนี้พรุ่งนี้สบายดีไหม
สบายดีอิ่มพึ่งกินข้าวมาพรุ่งนี้คุณมีกิน
ข้าวตอนกี่โมงคือคนนี้กับจินข้าวตอน
ประมาณ
เกือบเกือบ
20:00 น
ใช่เป็นปกติใช่ไหมที่ถามว่าเป็นปกติมั้ย
ปกติเนี่ยก็
คือปกติจะกินประมาณ 19:00 นไม่อยากกิน
ข้าวดึกเพราะกลัวอ้วนแต่พอดีไปกินข้าว
ข้างนอกแล้วคนมันเยอะร้านมันยุ่งอาหารไป
มาช้าชายก็กว่าจะได้อาหารเกือบ 20:00 น
แล้วกินเสร็จแล้วก็กลับตากแล้วก็มามีอะไร
ไหมคะไม่นอนยังไม่นอนเพราะว่าต้องมานี่ไง
ภาษาไทย
ให้ดีแล้วถ้าเกิดแบบนอนไปเลยอ่ะก็จะแบบ
น่าจะไม่สบายนะคือไม่น่าจะไม่แม่สบายอาจ
จะด้วยมั้งครับแต่น่าจะไม่ตื่นหรอน่าจะ
หลับยาวจนถึงอีกวันนึงเลยก็คือจะไม่ได้มา
คุยกับเปี่ยมก็จะไม่ได้มาคุยแล้วกูเรียว
ก็อาจจะรอไว้ทำไมคนนี้แกไม่มาคือคุณไม่
กลับ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ไม่ใช่อ๋อต่อตอนนี้ก็ผ่านไปแล้วประมาณ
เกือบชั่วโมงแล้วเขาตอนนี้ที่ถ่ายเนี่ย
9:00 น 9 โมง 9 นาทีนใช่ 9 โมง 9 นาที
เนาะตอนเช้าใช่เพราะว่าที่นี่ก็คือ 09:09
คุณนี้กิวก็คือนี้ 09:09 น
เลยใช่คือของคุณนี้น่าจะช้ากว่านะก็คือ
ขอบคุณพฤหัสบดีของผู้เรียนก็เป็นวันศุกร์
ใช่เดี๋ยวนะเดี๋ยวของละวันนี้วันเสาร์ๆ
ส่งของผู้เรียนมาวันเสาร์ใช่
คุณนี้ก็ดูปฏิทินในคอมแล้วก็คือวันศุกร์
แต่เดี๋ยวนะวันศุกร์ของที่นำเอริกาสิชาย
คือใช่เพราะว่าวันนี้วันวันเสาร์
วันเสาร์วันที่ 20 ครับชายายนต์หยุดวัน
ศุกร์ที่ 9 กันยายน
เราห่างกัน 12 ชั่วโมงใช่ห่างการศึก 2
ชั่วโมงครับ
โอเคค่ะพรุ่งนี้ครับเตรียมได้ยินว่า
เหมือนเราเคยคุยกันเรื่องหนังผีที่แบบ
เวลาอยู่อาเมริกาหลายๆคนจะไม่ดูหนังไทย
เพราะว่ากลัวหลายๆคนไม่ดูหนังอะไรนะไม่ดู
หนังอเมริกาอาจจะไม่ดูหนังผีไทยซึ่งคือ
เพราะว่าคุณนิคแน่เป็นคนกลัวผีเออจริงๆ
แล้วจะบอกว่าตอนนี้กลัวผีไหมก็ไม่อยากพูด
ว่าไม่กลัวเลยเพราะว่าเดี๋ยวถ้าเกิดว่า
พูดไปแล้วอยู่ดีๆคืนนี้มา
ว่าเรากลัวน้อยลงดีกว่าอ๋อ
เดี๋ยวแบบดีๆแบบมาแล้วแบบไม่กลัวเหรอใช่
ก็เลยขอกลัวน้อยลงกลัวน้อยลงเพราะว่า
เหมือนกับตอนนี้พอเราโตขึ้นเพราะเวลามัน
อะไรแปลกๆนะคือคุณนี้ก็จะคิดแล้วว่า
เหมือนกับมันจะต้องหาเหตุผลหรือเกี่ยวกับ
วิทยาศาสตร์ว่าเอ๊ะมันไม่ใช่ผีหลอกมันน่า
จะเป็นตั้ง
แต่ตอนเด็กๆทูนิคเชื่อไหมครูนิเชื่อไหม
จริงๆตอนเด็กๆแบบคุณอีกเชื่อแต่เชื่อ
เพราะว่าที่บ้านครูนิดเนี่ยเอ่อแม่คุณนิค
พี่สาวคุณนิดเนี่ยเขาจะมีความเชื่อเกี่ยว
กับคนไทยที่เชื่อการอ่านหรือเกี่ยวกับผี
แบบนี้แล้วก็จะได้ยินมาตั้งแต่เด็กแล้วพอ
เราได้ยินตั้งแต่เด็กเราก็เลยแบบมันจะจำ
จำ
ใช่ใช่บางทีมันก็ทำให้เรากลัวเนอะแล้ว
เรื่องบางอย่างเราไม่รู้ว่าจริงไม่จริง
เขาพูดเพื่อให้เราทำบางอย่างที่เขาต้อง
หลานให้เธอเหมือนกับเขาพูดมาเราก็โอเค
โอเคฟังแล้วก็ทำตามที่เขาบอก
ๆแล้วคุยครูนี้จำได้ไหมคะว่ามีความเชื่อ
อะไรบ้างที่ใหญ่บอกเราหาว่าจำได้ไหมพอจำ
ได้บ้างจำได้บ้างจำได้บ้างบางเรื่องนะคือ
เคยได้ยินว่าความเชื่อคนไทยมันมีเยอะมาก
แบบเป็นร้อยอ่ะเป็นร้อยความเชื่อแล้วก็
แต่ละที่และก็จะความเชื่อไม่เหมือนกัน
เหมือนกับภาคเหนือคนเชียงใหม่คนลำพูนหรือ
ภาคใต้คนภูเก็ตคน
สุราษฎร์ยกตัวอย่างนะครับเขาก็จะมีความ
เชื่อไม่เหมือนกันแบ่งก็เลยจะมีความเชื่อ
เยอะมากคุณนิดนะจำได้จำได้ประมาณน่าจะ 10
10 กว่าสึกกว่าความเชื่อประมาณนั้นๆไม่
จำได้จนถึงตอนนี้ตอนนี้จะให้จำได้ถึงตอน
นี้ครับก็
อย่างแรกเลยเนี่ยถ้าเกี่ยวกับผีนะความ
เชื่อความเชื่อแรกก็คือ
ที่ได้ยินมาแล้วเขาก็บอกว่าถ้า
ก็เหมือนกับมีเด็กเด็กแรกเกิดเนาะก็คือ
เด็กที่เพิ่งคลอดมาเลยแว้วแว้วมาเลยแล้ว
เขาบอกว่าถ้าเด็กคนนั้นน่ะถึงเราดูแล้ว
เด็กน่ารักขนาดไหนเราห้ามพูดว่าเด็กหน้า
เธออันนี้เริ่มเคยได้ยินมาคือเหมือนเขาจะ
พูดว่าถ้าเกิดว่าน่ารักให้ผู้ว่าเด็ก
เนี่ยน่าเกลียดหรือน่าชั้ง
เออแบบไม่สวยใช่
แล้วคู่นี้คิดว่าทำไมเขาถึงบอกว่าห้ามพูด
คืออันนี้เนี่ยที่คุณนึกได้ยินมาก็คือเขา
บอกว่าเพราะคนไทยจับผีแล้วนะมันก็จะ
เหมือนจะอยู่ด้วยกันมาตลอดเป็นความเชื่อ
เขาบอกว่าถ้า
ถ้าบอกกับเหมือนกระทั่งเด็กแรกเกิดเนี่ย
แล้วเราบอกว่าน่ารักอ่ะ
หมอเขาทีอ่ะจะมาเอาเด็กไป
ก็คือทำให้เด็กตายหรือว่าเด็กหายไปใช่แบบ
นั้นเขาก็เลยมันก็เป็นความเชื่อคนไทยของ
สมัยก่อนนะว่าถ้ามีเหมือนกันเด็กแรกเกิด
เด็กที่เพิ่งคลอดออกมาเนี่ยน่ารักขนาดไหน
ถ้าเราอยากพูดก็จะต้องบอกว่าไม่น่ารักพอ
เราพูดไม่น่ารักที่ได้ยินผีก็จะไม่มาบ้าน
เขาโทษบ้านนี้เด็กไม่น่ารักไม่มาพอได้ยิน
คนบอกว่าไม่น่ารัก
อันนี้หรอกผีหรอคนหลอกผีใช่คือคือคนหลอก
ผีจริงๆผีอ่ะต้องหลอกคนใช่แล้วคุณนี้คิด
ว่ายังไงคะพรุ่งนี้เชื่อไหมคือถามว่าคุณ
นิดเชื่อไหมคือตอนนี้เนี่ยคุณนี้ก็
คิดให้คำว่าไม่ผมชื่อร้อยไม่เชื่อดีกว่า
แต่คือเราคนไทยจะบอกว่าอย่างนี้ว่าคือถ้า
เราไม่เชื่อแต่เราก็จะไม่ลบลูม
ขึ้นเหมือนกับโอเคเราไม่เชื่อเรารู้สึก
ว่าพูดแบบนั้นน่ะมันก็
ยังไงอ้ะมันฟังดูแล้วมันแตกแปลกแต่ผู้
ใหญ่นะคนที่อายุมากกว่าเราเขายังมีความ
เชื่อแบบนั้นแล้วเยอะเอาถ้าพูดง่ายๆก็คือ
ไม่ใช่ลูกเราอ่ะเขาอยากให้พูดยังไงเราก็
พูดไปเถอะจะให้ใช่ๆแล้วอีกอย่างนึงเนาะ
แบบที่เขาบอกว่าไม่เชื่ออย่าลบหลู่ก็คือ
เราไม่เชื่อก็ไม่ต้องไปพูดว่าคนอื่นไม่ดี
ค่อมปล่อยให้เขาเชื่อไปทยก็คือการลบหลู่
มันก็เหมือนกับเหมือนเราไปคือถ้าสมมุติ
เราไม่เชื่อแล้วไม่ต้องไปพูดเอากี่ดอกก็
เงียบๆอยู่ของเราไม่ต้องไปบอกว่าโอ๊ย
เชื่อทำไมเนี่ยมันไม่จริงไม่ต้องไปทำตาม
แบบเนี้ยเขาจะคบก็จะบอกว่าลบหลู่แล้วการ
ลบหลู่แล้วมันก็เหมือนจากการไม่เคารพไม่
มันก็ไปบอกให้คนอื่นว่าไม่ต้องเชื่อไม่
ต้องทำตามตามนั้นใช่เราจะใช้คำนี้กับ
เรื่องของความเชื่อน่ะใช่ใช่สำหรับเรียม
เองนะเรื่องนี้เรียนคิดว่าอาจจะไม่ใช่ผี
นะอาจจะเป็นคนที่มาขโมยเด็กที่น่ารักก็
ได้นั้นเออคือตอนนี้น่ะคุณไม่คิดว่ามันก็
อาจจะเป็นแบบนั้นมากกว่า
เพราะว่าปัจจุบันนี้มันก็มี
มีอะไรแปลกๆ
เยอะคนที่แปลกๆเยอะ
แรกๆเลยก็อะที่ยังกูเรียนบอกแต่ว่าถ้าบอก
ว่าลูกน่ารักลูกแบบโอ๊ยเห็นแล้วเป็นดูน่า
รักอยากเอาไปเลี้ยงแล้วถ้ากดหน้านะได้
เดินผ่านมาแล้วได้ยินว่าอ้อน่ารักใช่ไหม
เดี๋ยวจะขโมยไปใช่มีแบบนั้นจริงๆๆใช่ๆ
นั้นหน่ะคือสำหรับคนนี้ก็คือเป็นความ
เชื่อที่เกี่ยวกับผีแล้วก็คนไทย
ผู้เรียนมีไหม x ความเชื่ออะไรเกี่ยวกับ
คนไทยไหมที่ของเรียนหรอของเรียนที่จำแล้ว
ก็เห็นคนอื่นทำก็คือเค้าจะไม่ตัดผมวันพุธ
กันเออ
นั่นแหละไปร้านตัดผมก็เอาร้านตัดผมไม่
เปิดวันพุธ
ผู้เรียนสุดก็
คิดว่าทำไมถึงตัดผมวันพุธที่ 4 คือเรียม
เคยไป Google ดูนะคะเขาบอกว่าวันพุธเนี่ย
เป็นวันตัดผมของพระราชา
ไม่ใช่วันตัดผมของคนทั่วไปเอ่อครับนั่น
แหละแต่ลืมก็ยังไม่เข้าใจเหรอว่าทำไมเรา
ต้องแบ่งกันว่าวันนี้พระราชาวันนี้คนทั่ว
ไปเพราะว่าส่วนตัวเต็มไม่ได้เชื่อ
คือคือคุณอีกแน่ก็ได้ได้ยินเหมือนกันกับ
ที่ครูเรียมหาใน Google นั่นแหละคุณนี้ก็
เลยเข้าใจว่าอาจจะ
สมัยก่อนหลังครับที่พระราชาจะตัดผมวันพุธ
แล้วถ้าคนอื่นตัดวันเดียวกันพระราชาอัด
เน้นความที่ของคุณอีกนะคุณคิดว่าอาจจะถ้ำ
มีคนที่ตัดวันพุธเหมือนกันกับพระราชา
เนี่ยเอ่อถ้าสมมติช่างตัดผมพระราชาไปตัด
ให้คนอื่นเรามาตัดให้ประชาไม่ได้เผื่อกับ
ว่าประกาศเคลียร์ทำให้ตารางช่างตัดผมว่าง
ไปเลยให้กับพระราชทานเกี่ยวคุณมีกี่แบบ
นั้นน้อหนูเป็นมุมมองใหม่มากเรียงก็กับ
คิดว่าขอสำหรับพระราชาทุกอย่างต้องพิเศษ
มือก็กับการคนอื่นๆๆแต่แค่คุณนี้คิดว่า
อาจจะเป็นเพราะเขาอาจจะเหมือนกับให้ตัด
ปัญหาไปเลยว่าเออก็พระราชาตัดวันพุธใช่
ไหมคนอื่นก็ไม่ต้องตัดเพราะว่าเดี๋ยวไม่
มีช่างตัดผมให้พระราชา
สูงสุดยอด
คนนี้คิดได้ไงอ่ะแต่
ถามว่าตอนนี้อันนั้นน่ะเป็นความเชื่อของ
คนไทยที่คุณนิดนำไม่ได้ทำตามเพราะคุณนี้
จะมองว่ามันเป็นเรื่องที่มัน
ก็คือแปลก
เงินแปลกสำหรับสนีย์ตัวนี้เตรียมลืมบอก
ว่าเรียนไม่เชื่อว่าตัดผมวันพุธไม่ดีใช่
ไหมแต่เรียมเคยได้ยินว่าตัดผมวันจันทร์
กับวันศุกร์ดีและเวลาเรียนจะตัดผมแล้วก็
คิดนะเนื้อนี่วันนี้วันอะไรนะ
พรุ่งนี้กลับไม่สนใจเลยคุณนี้น่าจะอยาก
ตัดผมวันไหนก็ตัดเลยคือคุณในแค่คิดว่าถ้า
เราอยากตัดแล้วร้านตัดผมเปิดช่างที่เรา
อยากต่างโช้คตัดใต้คนนี้ก็ตัด
[เพลง]
ใช่แต่ว่าตามประสบการณ์เรียมก็คือเรียน
รู้สึกว่าเออมันรู้สึกดีขึ้นที่แบบเออมัน
มีความหมายว่ามันดี
แค่นั้นเองก็โอเคอาจจะโอเคก็น่าจะเป็นไป
ได้ถ้าจะเป็นไปได้ได้คือแค่คนนี้คิดว่า
จริงๆคุณเล็กและก็
มีความคิดว่า
คุณนี้เป็นคนไทยแต่ขึ้นมันก็เป็นความ
เชื่อของคนไทยสำหรับคลินิกนะความคิดของ
คุณนี่คือเป็นความเชื่อของคนไทยที่อยู่ใน
ประเทศไทย
[เพลง]
ถ้าเป็นคนไทยที่อยู่ต่างประเทศขึ้นมาเป็น
ความเชื่อแบบนี้เนี้ยถ้าเราจะทำตามความ
เชื่อของคนไทยเวลาเราอยู่ต่างประเทศมันก็
ไม่ได้เพราะว่าคนที่อยู่ต่างประเทศเขาไม่
ได้มีความเชื่อมันเราเขาก็จะไม่ได้ทำอะไร
เหมือนเรายกตัวอย่างเหมือนอย่างถ้าที่บอก
ว่าให้บอกกับเด็กแรกเกิดว่าน่าเกลียดถ้า
สมมุติเป็นเราที่มีรูปมีลูกแล้วคลอดลูก
ต่างประเทศเพื่อนๆสิบคนมาหาแล้วบอกลูกน่า
รักลูกน่ารักคะแล้วเราบอกว่าห้ามพูด
คุณนี้ก็คิดว่าฝรั่งน่ะก็ไม่เข้าใจก็เอา
ทำไมมาบอกเธอก็ลูกน่ารักจริงๆจะให้บอกว่า
น่าเกลียดทำไม
หือหนูเข้าใจเลยเออ
คอร์สคุณนี้ก็พรุ่งนี้อยู่เหมือนกับว่า
คุณนิคจะ
จะพูดยังไงให้มันฟังดูไม่
ไม่ไม่น่าเกลียดคือคุณนี้ก็เหมือนกับใช้
เวลาอยู่ต่างประเทศบ่อยถ้าไม่คุณนิด
เหมือนก็มีความคิดว่าฝรั่งเขาจะคิดแบบนี้
คนต่างชาติเขาจะคิดแบบนี้มันก็จะทำให้
เข้ากับคนไทยไม่ได้ร้อยเปอร์เซ็นต์
น้องทำเองมันก็เลยทำให้คนคิดว่าเออ
จริงๆเราไม่จำเป็นจะต้องเอาความเชื่อค่า
ของคนไทยที่เราใช้ในประเทศไทยมาใช้ต่าง
ประเทศ
ใช่ๆเราก็อะไรนะความเชื่อที่เรียนน่ะกลัว
มากนะตอนเด็กๆนะที่พ่อแม่บอกว่าแบบเวลา
พระอาทิตย์ตกแล้วน่ะไม่ให้เล่นซ่อนหา
แบบตอนเด็กๆนะเราจะเล่นแบบซ่อนหาไปลบใน
ตู้
ใช่
น้ำเขาบอกไหมว่าทำไมถึงไม่เล่นซ่อนหาตอน
กลางคืนเขากลัวว่าแบบเหมือนแบบผีจะแบบมา
บังตาเหล่าเนี้ยเป็นผีอีกแล้วก็ผีแบบรู้
สึกว่าประเทศไทยผีเยอะมากเวลามีความเชื่อ
เนี่ยพูดถึงผีทำให้คุณในก็คิดเหมือนกัน
ว่าจริงๆแล้วอ่ะผีเนี่ยอาจจะเป็น
เหมือนเอามาเหมือนเป็นข้ออ้างเอามาพูดให้
คนกลัวอีกนะอีกแล้วเนี่ยความเชื่อมันก็จะ
มีความเชื่อบางอย่างที่เขาจะเอาไปพูดให้
เด็กแล้วเด็กอ่ะกลัวผีอยู่แล้วส่วนใหญ่นะ
สำหรับคุณนิดที่คิดว่าใช่ใช่
แล้วเราโตขึ้นมาตอนเด็กๆถ้าเราเชื่อไป
แล้วโตขึ้นมาเราก็จะมาพูดกับเด็กแบบที่
เราก็ไม่ได้เข้าใจว่าความจริงมันคืออะไร
นายมันก็เหมือนเป็นการพูดแบบปากต่อปาก
เหมือนกับว่าแม่ของเราพูดบอกเราจะตากแม่
มาให้เราฟังแล้วพอเราโตขึ้นจากปากเราก็
พูดกับเด็กคนอื่นนั้นแค่เดี๋ยวมาแบบที่
ที่ถ่ายมีความเชื่อเพราะอาจจะเป็นแบบนี้
แหละที่เราไม่ได้พูดความจริงแต่เราเอา
ความกลัวเอาความกลัวไปให้เด็กเอาไปให้คน
อื่นๆและเพื่อให้เขาทำตามสิ่งที่ต้องการ
เธอใช่ใช่จริงๆก็สำหรับคนนี้แกเรื่อง
เรื่องเรื่องของ
เล่นซ่อนหาเนี่ยที่ไม่ให้ไม่ให้เล่นตอน
กลางคืนคุณนี้คิดว่าเพราะมันอันตราย
เหมือนกับมันมืดแล้วสมัยก่อนอาจจะมันไม่
ได้มีตึกหรือไฟเหมือนบ้านเราหรือง่ายๆถ้า
ไปต่างจังหวัดเล่นซ่อนกลางคืนมันอันตราย
ว่าถ้าเราเล่นข้างนอกจะมีรถผ่านมาหรือไป
ซ่อนหาตรงไปซ่อนหาในแนะนาแล้วอาจจะตกดิน
หรือมีอะไรแล้วคนหาไม่ได้มาช่วยยากจะให้
ถ้าถามว่าเปล่าแต่ถ้าบอกผีสั่งแน่นอนแต่
ถ้าเกิดบอกเด็กสมมติว่าเราเป็นเด็กแล้ว
พ่อแม่บอกว่าไม่ให้เล่นและเย็นมืดแล้วไม่
ให้เล่นมันอันตรายคืนนี้คิดว่าเด็กเชื่อ
ไหมมันอันตราย
อันตรายอะไรไม่เห็นอันตรายเลยก็เล่นอยู่
หมายวันตามตารางไปทำไมก็เนี่ยเล่นอยู่
หน้าบ้านนะให้นั่นแหละคือเด็กลืมก็คิดว่า
เออนี่ก็คงเป็นแบบนั้นแหละ
เฮ้ยเขาก็เลยต้องเอาผีมาเอาพี่มา
จริงๆดีอันหนึ่งอันนี้เป็นความเชื่อที่
คุณนิคเนี่ยพึ่งได้ยินแล้วแต่ก็ไม่รู้ว่า
จริงไหมแต่มันก็ตลกดีเพราะว่าคือเหมือน
เมื่อไม่กี่ปีที่ผ่านมาเนี่ยแหละครับคือ
เราก็จะได้ยินแล้วว่ามันจะมีเหมือนกับ
ทำไมพูดเสียงหนึ่งเสียงสองเสียง 3 สมัยคน
นี้พูดหลายเสียงแล้วคุณนี้ก็ไปเจอว่ามัน
ก็มีความเชื่อของคนก็ได้เหมือนกันที่เขา
บอกว่าคนที่พูดหลายเสียง
ห้ามคบเป็นเพื่อนก็เขาบอกว่าคนที่พูดหลาย
เสียงเนี่ยเป็นคนที่ไม่แน่นอน
เป็นคนผิดคบยากเพราะว่าเสียงยังเลือกไม่
ได้ว่าจะพูดเสียงอะไรแบบว่าจะเป็นเพื่อน
กันน่ะจะเชื่อไม่ได้ฮึขอถ้าเกิดเสียง
หนึ่งของเดือนเป็นแบบนี้แล้วแบบเสียง 2
แบบๆๆออกคุณนี้กลางเธอทำไว้ยอมอันนี้
เริ่มเสียง 2 แล้วใช่ก็เขาก็บอกว่าขนาด
เสียงอ่ะยังเปลี่ยนได้หลายเสียงแล้วถ้า
เกิดว่าเป็นเพื่อนกันหรือทำงานด้วยกันถ้า
สมมติบอกว่าจะไปกินข้าว
แล้วอยู่ดีๆเปลี่ยนใจไม่อยากไปด้วยก็
เปลี่ยนได้ง่ายๆแบบนี้ก็ก็เพราะว่าเป็นคน
ที่คบยากถ้าคนมีหลายๆสีเหลืองลองตัวนี้
คิดว่ายังไงคบยากจริงไหมเรื่องเห็นเดี๋ยว
นี้หลายคนแบบมีสองเสียงนะบางทีก็แบบนี้
อันนี้เสียงที่ 10 หรือเปล่าคุยกับแฟนคุย
กับแม่ทำไมคนละ 10
หยุดจริงๆเป็นความเชื่อที่คุณนี้ก็ไม่ได้
เชื่อนะเพราะคุณคิดว่าคนที่มีเสียงหลาย
เสียงเนี่ยมันเพราะว่าเหมือนกับคุยกับแฟน
อีกเสียงนึงเพราะฟังแล้วดูน่ารัก
เยอะทำงานอีกเสียงเรื่องเพราะว่ายกตัว
อย่างว่าต้องเป็นหัวหน้าคนแล้วถ้าเรา
เสียงที่คุยกับแฟนยอร์ช
เพื่อนเสร็จหรือยังหรอเออเราเป็นหัวหน้า
คนไม่ได้ไม่มีใครฟัง
ใช่เออ
อันนั้นเป็นความคิดของคุณนิคุณนี้ก็คิด
ว่าบางคนที่มีหลายเสียงก็คือเขาอ่ะ
เปลี่ยนเสียงให้มันเหมาะสมให้มันเข้ากัน
กับ
สถานการณ์หรืองานที่เขาต้องทำใช่มันเรียน
คิดว่ามันเป็นความสุขแล้วก็เป็นสิ่งที่
เขาอยากเล่นน่ะใครก็ได้ใช่ใช่แต่ว่าตอน
นี้เวลาหมดแล้วค่ะครูนิคใช่ไหมใช่เวลาหมด
แล้วก็ไว้รอดูกันว่าเราจะคุยเรื่องอะไรใน
ครั้งต่อไปใช่ค่ะสำหรับวันนี้ต้องลาไป
ก่อนแล้วค่ะคืนนี้ก็ออกไปแล้วโอเคครับ
โคเรียมไว้คุยกันใหม่สวัสดีครับสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนไม่บายน